an important reminder about employment  rights labor rights week is recognized  in the days leading up to labor day well  the mexican consulate in las vegas says  it's a way for advocates to remind  workers that they should feel safe on  the job and know what is considered a  violation here in the valley there are  basic rights for everyone working  outdoors  shade and water that is a basic right of  all workers especially here in las vegas  that is so hot  all workers are entitled to breaks  in those breaks they should receive  enough water and also rest at the shade  that is very important  to avoid any health and safety issues  labor rights week has been going on for  the past 14 years it's recognized both  here and in mexico and several other  countries across central and latin  america